nicole pradier milite pour le parti
communiste depuis 1974
et pour elle la fête du muguet c'est
sacré c'est vraiment une vente militante
c'est à dire que ce n'est pas en me
levant pas une fleur comme on irait en
acheter chez le fleuriste mais ça
vraiment une signification demuth du de
lutte des travailleurs dans le monde
entier
secrétaire de section de conflent elle
est venue récupérer des plantes à
clochette pour les vendre le 1er mai
très des centres commerciaux prix d'un
pot de muguet 8 à 10 euros
une ressource importante pour le parti
qui a réalisé un score de moins de 3 %
aux dernières élections législatives en
une journée on est capable de faire
entre 2 et 3000 euros de bénéfices ce
qui nous permet à la fédération de
pouvoir maintenant souscrire pour la
liste de ian brossât pendant la campagne
électorale et en même temps de pouvoir
vivre tout temps de l'année 15 à 20 %
moyenne des recettes annuelles
c'est ce que rapportent les vente de
muguet au bureau du parti communiste des
yvelines
l'argent récolté permet de diffuser des
tracts des affiches ou de promouvoir le
journal l'humanité investissements donc
stratégique d'autant que cette action
militante touche un large public un
avantage loin d'être anodin à un mois
des élections européennes